whenever we ask any of the stars of ted
lasso
is season three the final season they
say ask jason
so
here you are
celebrating another big win
but what can you tell us about the
future of the show beyond season three
i think you've been misled
all right i don't because i don't i
don't know it's up to it's up to more
factors than myself
yeah are you are you saying that maybe
you would be up for doing a season four
are you
[Music]
i don't know i don't think i was
but now you are but i don't know if i
did
jason mike will there be a season 4 of
ted lasso
i don't know
so maybe
we got to do this off-broadway all right
who's on third exactly
i don't know uh yeah third base uh yeah
i don't know i you know it it the
the response to the show has been
overwhelming uh
we have a tremendous group of writers we
have a tremendous group of actors we
have tremendous you know people in
production post-production all of those
things are thrown into the jambalaya of
of possibility and so i i couldn't say
yes or no i do know that uh this this
you know part of the show uh is what
it's supposed to be and it and it will
be what it it
you know was fortunate to uh to become
based on all those added developments
but i you know as far as season four i i
apologize for not giving you um a more
direct answer because i understand that
that's helpful for headlines
i think the line was that this this
story that you're telling has a natural
end date
at the end of season three but then
there's maybe another story to be told
after that this is the same question
over and over and everybody and every no
ev you got 40 other people in here
everybody's okay with it i don't know
what power and you have over these
people but the fact that they let you
have this much time is remarkable i know
i still have the mind i know what do you
bring your own mic does everybody have a
mic is that why your name is mike
anybody else have a question
lady on the tv
she's just watching no mike i don't know
man i don't know i don't know if i knew
i wouldn't tell you they're taking the
mic away i wouldn't tell you
anybody else want to ask the same
question in a different way
[Laughter]
hi jason chanel janae here from the root
i'm definitely not going to ask that
same question so thank you you're
welcome uh one of the things i love
about ted lasso is the cast like i feel
like that's a such an important thing
when it comes to comedy series
so what can you say about the chemistry
between all the cast members here oh man
i like i hate being this whole voice for
all these folks i mean it's remarkable
it's remarkable like every single person
up here um gets along with each other
they support each other they're fans of
one another they respect one another uh
both as artists as human beings uh like
i've been lucky to to come from an
actual family where people do that for
each other i've been lucky to work at
places like second city and different
improv theaters i've been lucky to work
saturday night live during a generation
where we did do that so i don't know it
any differently for me personally uh so
but i but i know what i know and and
every every single day we show up at
work and every day we're away from each
other when we get to go to neat things
like this it's just fun it's just fun
people people care people care about
each other and
want to see the best for each other and
the best out of each other and that's
that's a remarkable thing and i
got lee what a terrific reason to do a
season four right mike
[Music]
[Laughter]
our next question comes virtually from
ashley with telltale tv all right
spiritually here
oh yeah hi hi
um congratulations um
i i wanted to get you to talk a little
bit about season two and the way that it
went into mental health um and it was
just such an important story could you
talk about the importance of that and
what it was like to to dive into those
stories of mental health gee whiz again
i feel like a jerk being the only one
talking about that i mean bill do you
mean like
i don't know what like we i mean we we
just
it was just something we had to do like
because
yeah
uh
it's first it's an excuse for all of us
to thank our fearless leader mr seday
because
and uh one of the things that he uh by
the way i'm gonna make a living out of
taking credit for other people's hard
work and i want to say thank you to all
the people up here because uh
i'd drink their blood if i could um
but one of the things that jason talked
about in the writer's room a lot was
especially in a pandemic
and with a lot of people out there
struggling was wanting to do stories
about mental health and self-care and i
thought the most clever thing that he
and brendan and uh uh joe kelly uh
brought to this
was a character that there was much more
beneath the surface than you could ever
imagine
and uh watching them watching that get
revealed the second season you know and
and the depth that it had i think that's
the reason that the show works and uh
kudos to to everybody for writing it and
for the way it was portrayed so it's a
good question because it was important
to all of
us yeah i mean we knew we knew we knew
ted was gonna have a panic attack in the
first season uh
and and just yeah we had we
there that we we feel uh um
compelled to explain why certain things
happen you know why rebecca is the way
she is why why nate you know goes on the
journey he goes on in season two um
i get played off here too
[Laughter]
you get it you get it but yeah so it's
just we had we you know we wanted to
explain what what um what ted was going
through as best we could and the fact
that people have responded to it and and
have felt themselves be seen through
that character um is um is you know
remarkable uh little do we know we're
all a lot more alike than you know um
variety will make us feel like sometimes
i don't know why mike you you became the
bad guy i don't know why
i don't know why it's nothing personal
it feels personal i get it it's not
i've never met you yes ma'am
our final question comes final question
is that because we had long answers
sorry either way you should do true and
false go ahead is it me okay
um congratulations i i want to know do
your kids think you're as funny as the
rest of the world does
does anyone's kids think there is funny
no no i i i don't i i don't know
um you know they um
they have a lot of notes but it's mostly
about structure
and length
believe it or not yeah they're they're
it's a lot of their county can we can we
shave some time here jason you know dad
um you know
but you know
i don't know you'd have to ask them but
they're not here
yet
yeah i lied we have one more question
and it's virtually from jordan good luck
hi i'm jason jordan from the mpbc
affiliate in kansas city
[Music]
um you have incorporated the wonderful
kansas city in stoning your seasons why
was it so important for you to include
the place that you called home and
what's it like to know that the world
now knows about the place that you once
called home oh gosh i don't think i'm
the one that put it on the map i think
you know the royals and the chiefs and
charlie parker and janelle monae and don
cheadle and
many many other artists and people uh
far greater than myself have added to
that uh knowledge but but much what we
talked about you know bill and joe and
brent and i like early on was that the
collective wisdom of the character and
the show was was a culmination of the
people creating it and so
you know being someone that that that
had um
you know a lot of like
influence on that kansas city was just
uh is is part of my soul it's it's where
i'm from it's where i where i was raised
it's where my my folks live and and
where a lot of good and bad things have
happened um to me and many other people
and so it's just it had to be in there
and so just just like the experience
that other people brought from their
hometowns it's just this one we you know
we we have stemming from
kansas city from back home
[Music]